I think I fixed the technical stuff back
watching Carlsen versus Ali Reza I have
no idea how long they're gonna play for
but I'll try and stick around for most
of it already pretty tired let me move
this stream notification thing a little
bit this way and people can't see this
in in my window
but there's 16 over 1600 spectators on
this game Omni chess looks like Magnus
is gonna win this one just easy mates on
the back ring and just zoom in here just
to show I lost it what is this this is
what happens when i zoom in and
unsuppressed
what just happened it took me to the
home page to get to my friends Carlsen
there you go yeah if people want to
watch live on me chess I'll leave a link
in the chat I think that's what most
people are doing why so few viewers says
pingu bingo disappeared that didn't show
up is a link
I mean there's probably a few viewers on
the stream because everyone's just
watching Magnus oddly chest I don't
think he's streaming though when he
played the title arena a few days ago a
lot of people discovered afterwards that
there was a livestream of him playing by
someone like in the same room as him I
was on periscope of all platforms it
wasn't on Twitch wasn't on YouTube I
didn't even realize periscope still
existed Oh Magnus is in trouble Queen c5
check forking the king and the rook this
is so nice I don't have to play but I
can still draw arrows and it's still
gonna be a time scramble like time is a
huge factor I'd probably rather be black
with slightly more time and the knight
I have a feeling White's going to
convert this
whoa he could have taken the Queen he
played king c6 he was probably expecting
king a7 yes either he could try
so darreth says it's incredibly common
how close real chests
these elite-level bullet games are until
the time scrambles ok this opening maybe
not the most real chests like okay most
of the openings are just like kind of
standard and it's still very strategic
in nature and this opening actually is
is not bad for bullets it's like white
has some nice peace harmony and it's
hard to crack as black this queenside
space advantage yeah like see 5d6 coming
looks like black is trying to go for
something with efore now he four is just
weak like look at whites pieces double
fianchetto two rooks in the center
blacks lacking coordination and space
before it's gonna fall that's a nice
outpost on e7 there's so many mating
ideas whoa Queen takes g6 pawn takes
knight takes King g8 Bishop e6 that's so
dirty there should be six birkoff seven
takes and then it's just mates that's so
amazing
oh so he still sack the Queen and okay
black sagging back wait what just
happened there okay I want to go real
quick slow-motion replay what just
happened
Queen takes g6 like I said there are so
many mating ideas and I was about to
take it back
but like this lion is so awesome there's
a v6 and then just meet on a sudden
Karlsson still ended up giving away the
queen and got enough play I guess the
computer didn't like Queen takes g6 but
in a bullet game it's just such a good
move okay so let's stay with the current
the current game Carlson's Queen on g3
92 it's reminiscent of the other game
blocks up the exchange but the rook is
trapped on g3 so it's actually a little
bit weird I guess f3 is a long-term
target though h5 is nice now g4 will
come at some points just with Chris and
the chats what's up
doctor like yeah doctor I don't know how
you said like nitrous tea nor nectar
Stein and Nick Turse Stein
it is Carlson Carlson has had several
different names on me chess under if
anyone in the chat can name like all of
the names that Carlson has had because
the most well-known one is dr. drunken
Stein but then there is man with a van
there's Danny the donkey is this one I
think there's a few others too
apparently whatever this name is it
means sober so okay what is going on
some dirty flag trying to occur I don't
know who's playing for a win like I can
just pre move everything yeah just to
draw
did they agree to a jar or was it 15
move rule o Kings gambit Falk your
counter gambits okay now we have to
think we call this a Basia variation
I think Carlson played this against
Aronian at some point in time so I
remember like studying some Kings gambit
games and looking at like highest-rated
players who played Kings gambit and
seeing Carlsen okay now ways away from
the opening somehow white is down by
blink for a moment and white is down a
bunch of pawns oh it's down three pawns
here what's he doing he has some
activity it takes he seven now he's only
down two pawns g5 nice move on black is
playing well it seems like White's hope
is saying I'd like some attack against
the King they're actually both these
pawns are hanging now this pawn who
falls in the Knights loose b6 he six
probably didn't really help at all yeah
rooks and knights can coordinate very
well like he wants to do this in this
and start targeting the King or even
better yet when h7
you can check but then the king can run
to d8 and black has counter played to
this might just be winning for black
rook h7 nice move threatening mates into
wow this rook is so annoying
it has like f1 d1 takes e5 ouch
this is mates why it was so easy to like
look at whites mating ideas forgot about
blacks mating ideas but Magnus was just
slow in time towards him there ah
so we have the the names oh so I don't
think I missed any doctor doctor drunken
Stein Danny the donkey dr. Victor
Steinem
Oh Magnus Carlsen I forgot about that
one that was like the first one I
remember like it was huge news that like
he had a verified account on me chess
with no games and then everyone followed
him and then he just came up with all
these like wacky anonymous accounts ala
Reza 2003 is a 15 year old GM from Iran
I don't know too much about him but he's
very very strong in blitz and bullets
clearly here like okay his lifetime
score did the stream just die there's a
little bit of drop out there the
lifetime score between these two is okay
I can't zoom in 43 and a half per magnus
29 and a half for ali reza and this is a
position which is normally just drawn in
slow chess but magnus i would put a lot
of money will win this
huge time advantage also better
structure but if this were a world
championship like if he's playing
against Fabien he's still probably
trying to play this out for a win we
just argue like there's targets on the H
file maybe put the King on h5 just be
careful putting the King on h5 though
because there's mating ideas for white
yeah there's no way White's gonna not
flag
but black ass still likes find some way
not to repeat the position
oh he repeated the position that's so
unfortunate good thing I didn't put a
lot of money on that now I think Maggie
was should've like pushed f-pawn earlier
of the King on that five-o we have some
French variation I was looking at this
line the other day this early Bishop III
seems like a lot of these games Magnus
is being tricky in the opening like
playing a lot of offbeat lines which you
see a lot in like amateur level play but
still like very playable in blitz or
bullets German chess player with a sub
99 thanks German chess player if you
like then find both would really like
your name all those nines
this is a fork so White's winning the
exchange but black has some pawns this
is a very nice move because this night
on eight he's trapped black wants to
focus on active play Queen c7 is a nice
move though both players being
resourceful because now white is just up
a rook for three pawns Oh like can't
take on c2 because Queen takes off one
it's a four but the Queen stays on this
diagonal if I can win the rook on c1
maybe there's some hope but black is
still down at nights and c2 Zargon her I
just queen take c2 should be easy win
wait what just with Chris I'm just
reading your comment am i concerned that
the government shutdown might impact my
ability to fly home could that actually
be an issue
I mean I'm planning to come home next
month I actually just booked my ticket
today if there's a real chance that wait
what is what just happened cleanup hate
oh they it was just a fancy Queen trade
oh he plundered wait what Oh Magnus is
trying to flag him but I feel like this
is one of Magnus's weaknesses is getting
in these time scramble situations but
okay both players are just ridiculously
fast it's hard to actually call her a
weakness but again like okay two games I
thought should have been really easy
wins but okay this guy is a fighter very
resourceful
does the TSA stop working if the
government shuts down was this opening I
look away for one moment than they're
like deep in the middle game
this is like the benoni Dutch opening
this is interesting opening like the
king is very safe on c7
Black has some Kings side play
huge time advantage like every game it
seems like Magnus is his way up on time
at least so far it seems like he's been
more impressive in the opening the TSA
keeps working
unpaid oh wait
that's not good obviously I've been a
little bit ignorant the last few days
two weeks because when you're in a
different country it's so easy to forget
what's going on like back home the ice
welcome back and Manas in the chats good
to see you guys
yeah the flight I booked earlier has
like a 24-hour free cancellation but it
was such a good deal that I don't really
want to cancel it
and actually the flight will get me it's
a flight from Africa to Chicago that
stops him like in Belgium and Canada so
the very least I can get to Canada and I
might drive back
black was hoping for some stalemate with
those Knights wasn't gonna happen yeah
I'm coming back to the u.s. next month
so hopefully the government is operating
at that point so now we have actually a
very normal opening like Queens gambit
declined Carlsbad structure very typical
f3 e4 plan neither five was some idea
but now 94 like this dark squares
maybe h4 h5 some game earlier I seeing
this plan I guess Queen takes h4 of
these some move okay so he's threatening
night at five nice threat and b7 so
attacking from all angles waiting for
him to play queen h6 just seems like
such a juicy square like Queen a
six-night g5 would have been my choice I
guess he's just winning pawns ouch so
current score is 41 to 30 at least in
these series of games is it over it
might be over
Oh Carlsen disconnected maybe he has
things to do in life apart from playing
bullets well that was fun I caught the
tail end of it this is actually a really
long match like they played 71 total
bullet games and a lot of them were just
really fascinating it's it is fun to
watch just high quality bullets and I
encourage people just say like go back
like play through the games I probably
caught the last I don't know five to ten
games there or more I don't know it's
hard to keep track of time
when it's so late so tired yeah I don't
think there's much more to talk about I
think I'll probably put this on YouTube
there's always some YouTube intrigue if
Carlson is in some way featured in the
video so for the YouTube audience hope
you guys enjoyed that hopefully we'll
see more of Carlson too and if we don't
then we'll see more of me